do you take this woman to be your lovely
leaded wife
[Laughter]
welcome guys we're here with another
video here for the podcast
yo preach get off your [ __ ] phone
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] you just gotta
demonetize the person
cause you were being a disrespectful
person that's okay we're gonna bleep it
out
well now that we're ready to start what
the hell is wrong with you what you mean
is wrong with me your voice bro
well
well catch me early in the morning
they say earlier they say morning sex is
the best i say morning voice is the best
yeah it is i gotta admit i had to train
i had to train to keep my morning voice
yeah all day long it's worked though you
know what thing is your morning voice is
actually your real voice is it it is and
because it goes higher throughout the
rest of the day because your voice has
stress
that's the reason why but your morning
voice
is the best voice
too much work
i mean i could certainly sit down i get
money like that i don't give a [ __ ]
even though it's good for the weight
it's good
no
no
you're not going to imagine imagine
trying to do stand up like that
well the bands are
because you've got like a deadpan style
you know i feel like that voice doesn't
translate well
i don't know a single comedian sounds
like that
dude
no exactly
i hope
i don't play any singers who sound like
that but make sure they make it
yeah
yeah definitely
i don't i don't think you could do the
only one that didn't
the only one i didn't make an effort was
barry st stand up is not supposed to be
sexy
no when i do it baby
[Laughter]
what's up with lebanese people in hairy
arms
hey don't give away my material bro
that's half my egg no i don't think i
don't think it's supposed to be sexy
it's not i don't think even especially
especially girls when they do something
like stand up and they do sexy they get
hate from both sides yeah the girl hate
on them and the guy that are with the
girls that are hating hate on them
because like i can't be like that girl
look good next to that girl that hates
her yeah because she looks good because
then i'm gonna hear it i'm gonna be
honest all night
if you're attractive i don't
that's a lot of people yeah yeah and
like when i say attractive i don't mean
like oh this guy's kind of tall or this
girl's kind of she has some big deal i
mean like actually you know what the
thing is like uh what's that girl elijah
schlinger schlesinger
yeah yeah yeah
you ain't seen the chest on that her yo
she's attractive for sure for sure she
i would probably say stand up she's the
most attractive yeah and you don't take
it seriously but like who cares what i
think i mean i'm just saying i
understand but if you ask me like
you know obviously she's done her job so
it doesn't work but i mean if i'm at a
comedy club or i'm an open mic for
whatever reason i got to buy something
or it's like the dane cooks
right yeah like
basically the dude
yeah the backstreet boy he was a
backstreet he was a basketball and he
turned out to be a fraud later on you
know uh you know even though he had some
good bits or whatever but i don't know
for whatever
there's a bias there you say for
whatever reason it's not cause you don't
think they struggled
enough because you think they have like
that pretty privilege so there's no
struggle in that sense it's like what
have you lived that's gonna be so funny
about [ __ ] you look good you're like a
[ __ ] that is super funny it's
like ellen
but ellen wasn't rich rich but that's
just someone that starts doing comedy
like ti
and he starts doing comedy when he's a
rapper i'm like i can't take this [ __ ]
like you don't y'all need this it could
and it could be not like like you said
it's a bias but i understand what a like
for me where the bias is from it's like
what have you struggled
yeah it's not that they don't struggle i
think you're just you're in i feel like
comedians have to be are generally
outsiders so they observe from the
outside that's where they make their
functions yeah that's my purpose and
most of the communities that i know of
have appeared that way either people got
stuffed in locker rooms or got bullied
by other friends
that was like that's like the meta for
yeah
they all look like troglodytes right and
that's okay i'm not made of it but there
is a certain pattern there so for
whatever reason because i'm used to that
pattern if i see someone who's out of
that meta
was like i don't know something seems
off about that yeah that's what you're
saying i can't understand that's been
pretty consistent for me i can
understand yeah and i think what keeps
convenience going is needing that
validation
yes because the one time where you feel
like an outsider not just an outsider
but a [ __ ] cult leader is when you're
on stage
and they all listen [ __ ] i don't get
that anywhere else i know i don't yeah i
don't get that nowhere else and so you
go back up on stage looking for that but
if you're an attractive person say
you're already kind of adorned in a way
what i'm saying yeah are you happy that
you're going to be doing your setup in
the states
how do you see that happening i mean
just like stand up anywhere else i don't
really think it's special to be honest
no
you're going to be able to connect with
the crowd making sure you can connect
with people or youtube channels actually
people talking to people connects with
people i feel like it's no different
yeah you got to find the modes where you
like
but i'm not stressed about that
yeah you want to say something
yeah no i
i agree it's i feel like you're an
outsider
and you're like
trying to
um
almost like
redeem yourself for like a life of being
an outsider in a way of like listen you
ignored me for so long or at least you
feel that way it's not like i was you
know [ __ ] burying my head in the sand
for my whole life but it's like you feel
ignored you feel like your voice doesn't
matter and now you're like
you have a voice all of a sudden so when
somebody always had a voice and they
always felt heard it just it doesn't
feel like i don't i'm not interested in
what you have to say right you know
right
and i'm pretty sure there's a bit to be
like hot people be like oh we're
marginalized people just like see me for
my little mouth
shut up like it's a struggle but [ __ ]
you
like that's
one place that i really was like oh
stress about performing with haiti
really oh because i know the people i
know
i know how they don't take [ __ ] jokes
they don't
understand so
it's a lot of things that he feel like
cringy about that you can't talk about
you can't talk about
politics you can't talk about religion
it's weird when you talk about sex
right so like i was like oh my god
the more and more the dates were
happening and
and advancing were approaching the dates
that were about to go there tomorrow i
was like
this is a bad idea yeah
yeah i could see that that makes sense
it's just a bad idea it's just not fun i
had zero pressure on me no no of course
i was just there i'm like hey what's up
come on
right i could have said anything and
[ __ ] was with it and even if i
bond i was like man haitians are lame
anyways right so it wasn't an issue for
me
hey haitians are lame yabba-dabba-doo
[ __ ] what's up [ __ ]
yeah jibber-jabber yeah exactly
was that word
remember huh
he's just mad he's just mad because i
just one i really told him that his his
language was
jabba jabber yabba-dabba-doo he just got
it right just it just got stuck right
here
so let's get on to today's game
speaking of languages
speaking of languages yeah
so what's the rules hit us so the rules
are very simple
languagesquad.com anybody can go and
play this game sponsored by the turkish
immersion center
in case anyone was wondering
so there's uh
three different levels of difficulty
we're going with medium
i feel like i tried the easy little too
easy it gives you maybe 15 to 20
languages that you're going to hear
20 second excerpt from
and you're gonna have to guess which
language this is all right now it is
multiple choice so i do have three
choices for this first question and as
the questions go on you're gonna have
more choices it's gonna get harder all
right so we're medium we got 58
languages hold up can we just get the
question not get the multiple choice and
if we can't get something to ask for the
multiple choice yeah yeah that's exactly
so if you guys are really stuck and it
sounds like some yabba-dabba-doo [ __ ]
yeah then
i'll give you the options let's go okay
all right here we go
straight up final answer okay yeah you
said estonia okay so i'll tell you
finland is not
one of the three estonia is
fire you know why why
because i heard the word cultura which
means that it's latin based yes for sure
that's good that's one indication and
also some of the words gave me like
greek area cool that's why i want to
live in north so yeah okay hold up so so
we both got one guess so give us the
multiple choice
so the three choices are danish estonian
or albanian
okay hold up hold up hold on hold up
hold up
so
give us a b c i like where will that
what are they so a danish
b the estonian c l b
answer
you're saying danish you're saying
albanian yeah okay
uh
the answer is
estonian oh boy i already got it i
already guessed it yeah yeah you stupid
like that you asked for the letters
he said finish
i said estonia yeah he said danish and i
said estonian yeah you said estonian but
then you said c which is no no but i
thought i thought that was a guess i
thought he was saying it was one of the
multiple choice questions that's not
what you said at first you said first
we're going to guess and after that
you're going to give us the multiple
questions no no we're gonna guess and if
we don't get it right then we get the
multiple choice that's what i assumed uh
okay never mind why would i guess
estonian and then change it after i
thought it was estonian i thought you
heard albanian were like [ __ ] [ __ ] no no
i thought it was estonian you're like no
it's one of the multiple choice question
answers and then that was my first
estonia was in the middle was b right
but my whole point is yeah i said
estonia you're like it's one of the
multiple choice answers you didn't say
it's the answer so that's why i was
confused
because if he would have said finish
right or whatever and that was the
answer i would have just given it to him
yeah but the thing that happened that
was my first guess you know you're not
gonna take that one i'm not it was your
first guess but i had a lot of [ __ ] when
it was my first gift and we took away
because my final answer was not that so
what happened is in the multiple
questions there was estonian
what's the point of us guessing
beforehand hold on you asked
okay all right doesn't matter let's just
move on
next question i didn't get it just
soaked up that's so stupid
that's what i mean i give you a point as
a reference
foreign
this is like horn of africa huh this is
horn of africa there's a horn of africa
he's definitely yeah it's giving horn
africa fights really yeah
where
i can tell you this
it's not somalia no it's not djibouti
okay um
but i'm i'm it's definitely that area
so
i was probably gonna i'm going with
kenya i'm going to kenya yeah
yeah i'm it's corner of africa it's
definitely in africa i'm pretty i i
believe you i believe you i mean you're
an authority on this i feel no no
hold up hold up is this the way that you
sing like uh play back
us
yay hold up well you know what give me
the multiple choices give them
once you a multiple
multiple choices well do you want to get
you want to guess let's go okay
italian
they just play with us filipino or hosa
what's uh this that's what
is it is it also i don't know i didn't
hear any clicks in there though
no it's h h
language
is uh nigerian in nigeria it's spoken by
the hosa people also live in chad ghana
cameroon okay
central africa yeah
they were both getting kids
no we both get it we were both no we
don't no i wouldn't i would have guessed
it
you would have said it was filipino no
not based on the multiple choice yeah i
would have guessed that but i mean you
already guessed it before we had the
multiple choices just get the point no
no i didn't you said horn yeah i said
horns i didn't get it right yeah yo
i didn't get it right though i did it
yeah
all the time i want i don't want peace
i want problems hey hey listen give me
give me the diamonds give me the
diamonds
[ __ ]
i want problems no i want i want mine
when i earned mine i didn't earn that
one
yeah i want i guess dystonia a country
of like a hundred thousand people
i know one piece i say as a ref number
one i give you estonia for sure because
you guessed it before hearing anything
yeah well that's why i didn't know yeah
you said horn of africa which is not no
it's not there right no no it's
the country i was taking this [ __ ]
i want problems
all right
there's no way it would have been
filipino though no no or italian that's
fresh no that's the thing
you would have heard the multiple things
that holster like come on bro come on
brad
yeah
yeah sometimes that that's the thing the
multiple choices they give you
are so all over just ad-lib them next
time okay sounds good yeah we'll make it
harder yeah good call
basically like if he sees italian or
filipino with some [ __ ] like this just
say like chad
nigeria or like molly and then that
would be better for us yeah cool
all right we're getting better every
question yeah
question three
begins now
foreign
you know what it sounds german but it's
not coming this is not german yeah it's
closely it doesn't fully yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't fully yeah i'm gonna say
something weird i'm gonna say luxembourg
okay
you say austria i say luxembourg okay
i'll give you three choices
uh we're gonna say is it dutch norwegian
or afrikaans
oh [ __ ] i'll play that [ __ ] back then
yeah
welcome back
this is
afrikaans or norwegian yeah
i'm saying so so north africans
i'm so african african i'm gonna say
norwegian and that's a [ __ ] because
dutch and africa are similar
you know what i'm literally debating
between norwegian and afrikaans and i'm
going to go to norwegian
okay the correct answer is afrikaans
yeah that's what i was eating
no no no i wanted to see if that would
normally be the wild card because it
sounded like dutch but i knew it wasn't
yet that's why i wasn't looking at that
one yeah it does don't sound like it's
dutch sounds a little bit more english
than that raspier yeah yeah yeah dutch
sounds like you're spitting a little too
yeah it's got a bit of arabic
yes yeah and dutch is close to german
for me yeah yeah
we both
we will start playing the same area
yeah yeah so i'm like yo we're gonna do
lab tests on human beings
there's something about germans like in
mad scientists that just seem to go
together you know what i'm saying yes
like if i heard somebody gets dissected
by a person i expect them to have german
germans yeah yeah built for efficiency
yes
let's go this next one's gonna be too
easy i'm gonna have to play it still
feels like winter for many people but
spring get the [ __ ] if you guys
[ __ ] us up
i didn't
i didn't hold up
wait let's let's see okay okay okay
let's [ __ ] with this wha what where is
this guy from i don't even know but
let's riff on it okay let's play
still feels like winter for many people
but spring today is officially here
which means flowers gardens and bugs
one man could not be happier about the
return of the insects especially the
ones that hurt isn't he that old geezer
who works for the bbc no he's a he's a
newscaster from mississauga
that's exactly
stop
stop stop i feel like he's that guy who
does like reports from mcclain he's like
the the the trudeau government has made
sure that today they're going to be
engaging in policies
he sounds like he works in media yeah
yeah yeah i mean i don't know i'm just
agreeing with the thoughts it sounds
like
that's not the thing final answer yeah
all right mississauga is the correct
answer i'm just saying that turkish
immersion center
all right
question five uh you're not gonna say
the answer
yeah mississauga
well actually it was uh it was uh
peterborough ontario but you're close
enough are you serious no no i don't
know
it's stupid i was like
the options were english french or
afrikaans wow again which is weird
because i'm playing this in english the
whole website is in english so why would
you give me that as part of the question
that's crazy
what
this whole thing was craze
this [ __ ] just this [ __ ]
sounds like he just did shrooms and that
[ __ ] just hit yo
that language is so crazy
it's vibrant
rav i didn't know if i was in [ __ ]
kazakhstan or latin america i didn't
even know if i was like in latin america
or greece yeah
it really felt like a crossover
so i'm gonna say catalan
i'm gonna say turkey
you're saying turkey and you're saying
oh
that could make a whole lot of [ __ ]
sense b yeah i don't know interesting
turkey and you're saying catalan catalan
okay um
no okay i'm going to give you three
options now of those yeah is it
romanian
latvian or greek
all right
that's hard because my greek is not as
push for me to [ __ ] than that but
you need you know what i feel i feel
like i'd be better understand greek from
women than men i don't know yeah if you
got a female voice
let me ask the algorithm can you ask the
[ __ ] to say to ziki sauce
all right uh you want to guess
i'm reading from i guess
that's either latvian
romanian or greek can you play that [ __ ]
back
i will say that my turkish guest was way
closer yes
yes
you're closer than catalan yeah yeah
i just want to ring something else
honestly i could hear the spanish in it
too uh so what you thinking greek
greek i'm going to go with b latvia
the correct answer is greek
yeah
you know what when i said turkey and
greece no no no yeah that that's why i
said you made [ __ ] fans but yeah that
was yeah the greeks would be very mad at
that but yes
would be [ __ ] mad at me if i didn't
get it yeah
he's gonna
what do you mean
he would be super mad at me yeah the
greeks have i find this this ass like
this this and the chorus
yeah the ph yeah yeah
and that's what it is
yeah
foreign
you ever just try to speak gibberish
languages you know what i mean what do
you mean
i don't know you're just like uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's a guy i don't know who it was he
used to make videos
yeah he's only youtube doing a
video so there's a guy who does his
videos right and it's him speaking
english but it's not actually english it
just sounds like english and so they're
having a full-on conversation of just
gibberish yeah but it sounds like
english phonetics so it [ __ ] with your
brain phonics is the same yeah yeah yeah
so i even trying to speak like that
would like scramble my mind but you make
it you start to realize like oh english
comes from a certain place yeah there's
a there's a there's a sonority to it
it's like a sound yeah when i was a kid
i was and i didn't know how to speak
english i would fake that [ __ ] like that
i would do that when i was a kid yeah
so it's really just repeating what you
hear because you don't know what the you
don't know what you're saying
so you just imitate well coma la fave
and if um
speak word for all
you're doing
all right what was that
nothing absolutely oh that's your fake
english that was yeah yeah yeah that was
nothing sounded like everything like
brazilian and
i wanted to try to do i didn't realize i
don't have the skill for it
it's a fun exercise when you're just
bored trying to speak gibberish when you
speak the language is very hard yeah
when you for sure yeah
the language is easy because you don't
know the language
yeah yeah yeah
sleeper kelly okay all right
that's sad let's get easy for me to
speak gibberish you know mandarin yeah
for sure
yeah is not an accident i'm used to but
i like portuguese
[Music]
i saw this
yeah so
i think both of our guests was gonna be
portuguese
um
it is not
one of the three
[ __ ] up accent that i didn't
understand all right sorry i got lost
here like i saw this yeah
maybe it's from cap village one of them
it's rounder
okay so is it
romanian
lithuanian or greek
romanian then
you're saying
play it again
that's [ __ ] up
athleticism
is that really what romanian sounds like
i don't know but i mean i heard it back
in the days i've never heard romanian
and romanian is a latin language
it's latin
it's one of the nine latino languages
man you don't be classy this [ __ ] was
still greek
[Laughter]
that would be locked with that would be
hilarious it might be look at his face
you never know it's one of the choices
um romanian
just saying lithuanian or greek
oh school lithuanian let's have some fun
it's it's greek again oh wow they back
to back greet us yeah say that again
play that again it sounded like
portuguese bro
the thing is that you have to [ __ ]
separate the words like when now you say
it i understand that she said
yeah but other than that i wouldn't
guess i'm gonna hold that up yeah oh
yeah i hold it live impressive it didn't
sound like luther in your room and
romania didn't sound like that to me so
i was like i can't say romania it's
weird greek is weird though yeah greek
sounds weird that should sound like
portuguese that didn't sound like that's
something that i'm used to maybe it's
montreal greeks
yeah yeah
all they all they do is say to ziki saw
so they didn't really count yeah
bro you want extra tahiki bro
it's not jiros
uh
okay i think so i wouldn't i don't want
to put my hand on fire
but
the way it spelled it wouldn't sound
like
gyro
i feel like it's
[Laughter]
just i don't want to admit i've been
saying you're wrong my whole life i
never ordered so who cares
not g but i'm getting i'm getting greek
right after this [ __ ] thing yeah i
feel like i've been agreeing
with me to order it no no
there's like a spot near my place do you
get
[Music]
shout out to greek town and laval have
you ever have you ever found yourself in
lithuania i've never been without
no no there's no reason i haven't been
there like four years
ago
greek town bro last time i went for a
comedy show and
you're not doing that show never again
yeah
he's like yeah
never again yeah i got too many
resources here that opportunity off the
bridge fair enough hit us with the next
one i live there and i don't want to go
back
do you live there now i live impaction
abandoning your kids and your family
and moving to the bunch [ __ ]
like i live there now and i'll never
cross that i don't want to go back [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i'm not crossing the bridge
i'm just thinking about y'all yeah
all right hit us all right next one god
i was so worried where are you [ __ ] i
left
yeah there it is so now you get four
choices as the questions go along you
get more uh okay more choices
here we go
all right
and this sounds like that like this
sounds like abba trying to order some
[ __ ] to people that don't speak his
language
we were in a restaurant he tried to
speak america
he was starting
nobody answered it it was like whatever
what did they say
what do you mean where you understood it
no oh i stopped listening halfway when i
realized i'm like you so stupid
once i realized it was my language i was
like oh my base
that's why right at the beginning i was
like this is
[Music]
yeah
give him the point you don't take it you
know you got the point that's yours it
sounds like alba try to
try to order some [ __ ] that nobody wants
to be
shut up
we're in america here give him that
point
give him that point three to one
what happens to me in arabic too huh
that happens to me in arabic also oh
yeah bro when i came back from i lived
in korea for a bit when i came back i
would go to korean restaurants and i
thought they would think i was like
cool and cultured for speaking korean no
no they don't care no i'd be like
and they're like um yeah you want the
chicken
that's nice okay you know that's
fantastic they're like stop you want you
want a beer okay wow you [ __ ] nerd
and i realize now that like yeah that's
a [ __ ] stupid dude even when i was in
haiti and i was talking that's just
another cultural thing when i was in
haiti and would start i tried to speak
crawl with them they were like you know
i'm i'm i speak french just because of
the situation in haiti where
when everybody speaks
creole so when you show that you speak
french you're just you're boasting i
mean you're showing that so when they
would speak french with me it's like an
i'm cultured
so when i was speaking creole with them
like especially white haitians
i was freaking real with them and they
were looking at me funny they were like
nah man
i could speak
better than you i could speak french
okay i speak french you don't have to
stoop down to that level
and i'm not your friend it's like you
speak real with your friends and i'm
like i just barely met you so
much
[Music]
yes this sounds like a place that's
being invaded right now yeah it's being
bombed yes this sounds like a place
where war crimes are prominent sounds
like a place where every day [ __ ]
don't get on trains and they don't
choose
like a place where a comic really can't
be president yeah you know
this sounds like a place that's soon
going to be part of russia yeah it
sounds like a place
where people eat pierogies
and a lot of potatoes my first and final
guess will be ukraine
so you're close but it ukraine is not
one of the options the russian
nor is russian okay so i'll give you
four
is it gonna be
yeah
[Music]
is it slovak
is it serbian
czech or slovenian
okay not the same [ __ ] yeah
it's like is it manitoba saskatchewan or
alberta [ __ ] it's the same country
different properties it's potatoes with
a little bit of coriander on it okay all
right all right so
potatoes [ __ ] yeah yeah okay just give
us options in order again
uh is it slovak
is it uh what did i say slovenian
uh
serbian or czech
i'm gonna go slovak
slovak is the correct answer i know it
was not the second one because you said
what did i say because you made that
[ __ ] up
[Laughter]
well they're giving me they gave me
hindi bengali and then the slovak and
it's like bro
i'm sorry all my my bengali is watching
we never gonna disrespect y'all that way
no yeah no no that's why i didn't want
to say it what did i say i was like
you [ __ ] up with that one yeah i'll
try to remember what i make of it
slovak
is number eight number nine
is
i'm gonna go with
i'll be
check
okay so
neither of those are right i'll give you
three options is it
norwegian
catalan
or macedonian
it's not got that long
is it play that [ __ ]
there's like 10 people there and a
volcano leave these [ __ ] alone
so macedonia
is so is it norwegian catalan or
macedonian
all right here we go macedonian yeah
macedonian is correct yeah it's not
norwegian no
there's missing a little no yeah yeah
it's like greek light yeah it's missing
a little iq
yeah oh island key oh ikea swedish same
thing [ __ ] [ __ ] out of here norway
finland sweden same [ __ ] yeah
the trifecta
you know it is the same almost exactly
the same language i didn't learn that i
didn't know that till recently like
nordic
like danish icelandic
uh swedish and norwegian are essentially
the same language but different dialects
an accent yeah just finnish is
completely different yeah oh yeah
it's wild wow does it border with
russian you
that's why
it's got a different vibe
finland's yeah finland borders russia
yeah you didn't know that that [ __ ] me
up too i found out recently because of
the whole ukraine thing
they share a border so they're terrified
of being invaded
you know what's wild that i learned from
playing that city guest or [ __ ]
russia has a random chunk at the top of
europe that's not even connected to
mainland russia that's called
it's kind of like alaska
exactly it has like a random chunk in
the middle of like i don't know estonia
lithuania whatever those other
maybe is it land or is it like an island
you know it's land it's landlocked it's
just a random chunk that's russia and
then there's three countries and then
there's russia that's crazy yeah and
there's a city called stalin and grad
dang yeah yeah the grad thing was common
in russia like saint petersburg used to
be called linen grad
i think grab means city
i think it's kind of dope though
should everything great
i'm dope yeah yeah i feel like just like
that kind of uniform for city names
leningrad stalingrad
whatever grad putin grad whatever you
want to do
i feel like it should be at some point
it's coming it's coming is it right yeah
i think when they take over ukraine you
should just call it
you imagine if ukraine became a province
called putin grant
i had insulted which is for fun calls it
because they grab your country make it
you make it here [ __ ] made a
slogan for that [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here
it is with the next one
question 10. here we go question 10.
if you have
[Music]
let's go to the next one okay
[Music]
he was trying to tell me i should be a
plumber
i started a new game when i went it's
all talking next we go next we don't
have to play i already know i heard two
seconds of this [ __ ] it's not like every
party i've been at montreal
[Applause]
shout out to my haitian people it's like
we know you know how we started
[Music]
yo they say so much i thought my letter
my name had an extra letter at the
beginning
[Applause]
[Music]
yo she got in front of stephanie [ __ ]
uh yeah
[Laughter]
you mean the esports no
[Music]
no esports
it's fought
sounded like jeremiah in this [ __ ]
spots
the crayon version of birthdays
[Music]
do you take this woman to be your lovely
leaded wife
[Laughter]
you know why this isn't funny because i
see that happen
you good
this [ __ ] is off
on the ground his phone is there you
[ __ ] the whole [ __ ] up
yeah you know
that's good that's a banger
careful
that time it was great
all right
sorry we had
we had to eat
oh that was stupid all right ah we're
good all right
okay
next one
is
go for it yes i got mine in the south
it's in the south what country going for
not likes yeah
go for it south africa i was gonna see
you guys
so i only have the language i don't know
necessarily what's the language
that you have
i'll give you three okay is it swahili
zulu or
losa rosa
give you that one
sorry about that i know you love south
africa
[ __ ] yeah yeah
i can't wait to go
why sir
[Laughter]
hey man listen i take cabs every now and
then and i'm not gonna lie even though
cabbage sometimes costs more than ubers
ryan with a haitian [ __ ] makes it worth
it this is different it is
boom
knife
[Music]
[Music]
um i was really interested
hey i'm gonna go with the answers right
away
the three choices all right i was good i
was gonna give my romanian guess
okay not romanian i'll give you guesses
is it hungarian
slovak thin or finish
is you done
yeah i know my answer
or is you feeling
hit him
uh you said slovak
hungarian slovak or finnish
hungarian
it's slovak again
they're trying to [ __ ] us up
turkish conversion center i met at that
they didn't even sound like the same
name
the other one sounded portuguese no it
sounded russian yeah this one didn't
sound russian at all
different dialects it's a different
dialogue i guess it must be that's why
we get some different things it actually
did not sound like the first one
whatsoever nope
all right hit us all right next one
yo
i don't say german
okay it's neither of those is it
icelandic
finnish hungarian
swedish or danish
i know i gave you like 45 answers
jesus christ
let me hear that
uh
what is it
is it icelandic
finnish hungarian
danish or swedish
finnish is different than swedish
swedish i think it's icelandic
it is indeed ikea
swedish yeah
because that's the most racist [ __ ] i'm
going to say
uh it really sounded like the swedish
chefs
[Laughter]
this is inherently just a guessing game
in that we both know the region we just
have no clue which one is what it is so
we just gotta get a multiple choice
right now yeah okay but let's get guess
we can randomly land on it okay urdu
okay and i was gonna go with bangla
okay it's near neither of those
just keep going hindi
sri lankan
so sri lanka has two official languages
it is one of them do you know what they
are
sri lankan and more dark
this is extra lagging
hey man listen listen let me give a
shout out to my sri lankan people i got
a lot of love for y'all
i mean you're not wrong
no he's not hey man hey listen sri
lankans are the [ __ ] of that area and
shout outs to them okay no they know
they know the struggle they know
i used to go to the school um
my name is
and uh
she was dark as hell and i used to love
it i used to be like amy you know you're
my favorite south asian
[Laughter]
because all the indians you know they
pride themselves off sometimes i'm being
light-skinned yeah wherever the sri
lankans are always kind of seen as the
more darker folks yeah um
i think i think it looks weird
yeah yeah
my a lot of sri lankans in my high
school so my best friend's going yeah
yeah the darkest dude in the world i
know was sri lankan yeah yeah yeah
there's just something funny about weird
[ __ ]
i have it here's the thing
but i get it you wanna know why i get it
this is why i tell i get it because when
i go to africa or go to kenya and i see
dark [ __ ] you know bald heads cool but
when i see ned flanders with like the
complexion of a kenyan it looks darker
for some reason because the the
juxtaposition between the [ __ ]
mushroom cut and the dark hair is crazy
crazy and sri lanka's got crazy looking
hair so shout out to them i get it i get
it
yeah if you see somebody from like black
panther looking dark like you don't even
really take it because they fall i'm
saying like yeah girl go do your thing
but you see that hair you're like
dude okay you came off the set of the
tsum tsums what's wrong bro
i just want to clarify i don't rank my
friends from dark delight i just happen
to notice this one particularly
your colorist ways
all right so don't look at that notebook
that's what i'm saying all right hit it
with the next one um so which one is it
so so sri lanka has sinali's and the
tamil
i mean
between the two i'll just say tamil but
um i don't i could be wrong i don't
think that tamil yeah all right i'll
take that one
okay well again that's a guessing game
yeah once you get to that area i'm like
actually
after that i don't listen to enough of
it no no same
and there's a lot of crossover and
similarity like urdu and hindi are
[Music]
[Music]
hungarian
romanian is the correct answer you
earned that one i will not
is obviously a land-based language yeah
you know what this game is how well do
you know europe
that's what this [ __ ] is
how well do you know how well do you
know europe i'm like bro i don't know
the difference between slovakians and
slovenians and checks
[ __ ] those names
it is very very
eurocentric for sure yeah yeah yeah they
couldn't get audio from a japanese
person
[Music]
[Laughter]
she shares the sea shells by the she's a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
uh unnecessary
[Music]
whether i say that english words i was
dying bro japanese people hearing me
rolling uh
benjamin button
unnecessary
i shout out to them because even the
french people were bugging out when they
were trying to say words oh yeah yeah
okay last one
hopefully go outside of europe
seminar conor
the website heard us like oh yeah that's
what you want yeah the algorithm were
like
i was about to
bust out my three words
i don't know why i keep saying words
like that man
all right who are we going to offend
next
hit us all right last one that's what
[Laughter]
this is like morse code what's going on
i don't think it's a real language
[Laughter]
word 10 times in one sentence
that sounds like morse code
i don't know
like it was a derogatory term yeah i'm
going to say
yeah i'm going to say
i'm trying to do i'm going to say chad
okay you're saying chad you're saying
packy i definitely think it's an african
diamond
okay uh
well yeah you know packy's not a
language
i mean my elementary school bullies
thought it was but uh
okay so so when i said that you saw
packy you thought i was dissing you
i'm not going live when i was growing up
the only time people said pacquiao was
like
there was never a possibility yeah
yeah it's like saying [ __ ] or black
yeah yeah
okay so this is the continent of africa
correct
incorrect i'll give you three uh
options is it thai
is it malay or is it tagalog
from philippines
malay
[Music]
this is what i do at home dude
this guy is whole pandemic
this whole pandemic all
right preach takes a dub today all right
well that was really good uh but that's
a lot of fun i enjoy these ones i enjoy
some about culture and language that
always makes me laugh yeah yeah so we
definitely do more of these uh but yeah
if you guys enjoyed today's video make
sure you guys like comment subscribe all
that good stuff encourage us also we put
up exclusive episodes on patreon only so
if you want to see those be sure to
subscribe there yeah
that's it man yeah peace